In this segment we introduce a
simple but powerful tool, the
basic counting principle, which
we will be using over
and over to deal with
counting problems.
Let me describe the idea through
a simple example.
You wake up in the morning and
you find that you have in your
closet 4 shirts, 3 ties,
and 2 jackets.
In how many different ways can
you get dressed today?
To answer this question, let
us think of the process of
getting dressed as consisting of
three steps, three stages.
You first choose a shirt, let's
say this one, and you
have 4 choices of shirts.
But each shirt can be used
together with 1 of the 3
available ties to make
3 different shirt-tie
combinations.
But since we had 4 choices for
the shirt, this means that we
have 4 times 3, equals 12,
shirt-tie combinations.
Finally, you choose a jacket.
Each shirt-tie combination can
go together with either
jacket, and so the fact that you
have 2 jackets available
doubles the number of options
that you have, leading to 24
different options overall.
So 24 is the answer to
this simple problem.
And how did the number
24 come about?
Well, 24 is the same as the
number of options you had in
the first stage times the number
of options you had in
the second stage times the
number of options you had in
the third stage.
Let us generalize.
Suppose we want to construct
some kind of object, and we're
going to construct it through a
sequential process, through
a sequence of r different
stages.
In the example that we just
considered, the number of
stages was equal to 3.
At each one of the stages, you
have a number of options that
are available.
So in our example, at the first
stage we had 4 options,
at the second stage we had 3
options, and at the last stage
we had 2 options.
What is important is that when
you reach stage i, no matter
what you chose, no matter what
you did at the previous
stages, the number of options
that you will have available
at stage i is going to be that
fixed number, n-sub-i.
So what is the answer?
How many different objects can
you construct this way?
Well, just generalizing from
what we did in our specific
example, the answer is the
product of the number of
choices or options that
you had at each stage.
This is the counting
principle.
It's a very simple idea,
but it is powerful.
It will allow us
to solve fairly
complicated counting problems.
However, before we go into more
complicated problems, let
us first deal with a few
relatively easy examples.
In our first example, let us
consider license plates that
consist of 2 letters followed
by 3 digits.
The question is, how
many different
license plates are there?
We think of the process of
constructing a license plate
as a sequential process.
At the first stage we choose a
letter, and we have 26 choices
for the first letter.
Then we need to choose the
second letter, and we have 26
choices for that one.
Then we choose the
first digit.
We have 10 choices for it.
We choose the second digit, for
which we have 10 choices.
And finally, we choose the last
digit, for which we also
have 10 choices.
So if you multiply these
numbers, you can find the
number of different license
plates that you can make with
2 letters followed
by 3 digits.
Now let us change the problem a
little bit and require that
no letter and no digit can
be used more than once.
So, let us think of a process
by which we could construct
license plates of this kind.
In the first stage, we choose
the first letter that goes to
the license plate, and
we have 26 choices.
Now, let us go into a second
stage where we choose the
second letter.
Because we used 1 letter in the
first stage, this means
that there's only 25 available
letters that can be used.
We only have 25 choices
at the second stage.
Now, let us start dealing
with the digits.
We choose the first digit, and
we have 10 choices for it.
However, when we go and choose
the next digit we will only
have 9 choices, because
1 of the digits has
already been used.
At this point, 2 digits have
been used, which means that at
the last stage we have only
8 digits to choose from.
So by multiplying these numbers,
we can find out the
answer to this question, the
number of license plates if
repetition is prohibited.
Let us now consider a
different example.
Suppose that we start
with a set that
consists of n elements.
What we want to do is
to take these n
elements and order them.
A terminology that's often used
here is that we want to
form a permutation of
these n elements.
One way of visualizing
permutations is to say that
we're going to take these
elements of the set, which are
unordered, and we're
going to place them
in a sequence slots.
So we create n slots.
And we want to put each one of
these elements into one of
these slots.
How do we go about it?
We think of putting the
elements into slots,
one slot at a time.
We first consider
the first slot.
We pick one of the elements
and put it there.
How many choices do we
have at this stage?
We have n choices, because we
can pick any of the available
elements and place
it in that slot.
Next, we pick another
element and put it
inside the second slot.
How many choices do we
have at this step?
Well, we have already used one
of the available elements,
which means that there's n minus
1 elements to choose
from at the next stage.
At this point, we have used
2 of the elements.
There is n minus 2
that are left.
We pick one of them and put it
in the third slot, and we have
n minus 2 choices
at this point.
We continue this way.
We keep going on.
At some point we have placed
n minus 1 of the
elements into slots.
There's only one element left,
and that element, necessarily,
will get into the last slot.
There are no choices to
be made at this point.
So the overall number of ways
that we can carry out this
process, put the elements into
the n slots, by the counting
principle is going to be the
product of the number of
choices that we had at each
one of the stages.
So it's the product of the
numbers n, n minus 1, n minus
2, all the way down to 1.
And this product we denote as a
shorthand this way, which we
read as n factorial.
n factorial is the product of
all integers from 1 all the
way up to n.
And in particular, the number of
permutations of n elements
is equal to n factorial.
Let us now consider
another example.
We start again with a
general set, which
consists of n elements.
And we're interested
in constructing a
subset of that set.
In how many different
ways can we do that?
How many different subsets
are there?
Let us think of a sequential
process through which we can
choose the subset.
The sequential process proceeds
by considering each
one of the elements of our
set, one at a time.
We first consider the
first element, and
here we have 2 choices.
Do we put it inside
the set or not?
So 2 choices for the
first element.
Then we consider the
second element.
Again, we have 2 choices.
Do we put it in the
subset or not?
We continue this way until we
consider all the elements.
There's n of them.
And the overall number of
choices that we have is the
product of 2 times 2 times
2, n times, which is 2
to the power n.
At this point, we can also do
a sanity check to make sure
that our answer is correct.
Let us consider the simple and
special case where n is equal
to 1, which means we're starting
with this set with 1
element, and we want to
find the number of
subsets that it has.
According to the answer that we
derived, this should have 2
to the first, that
is 2 subsets.
Which ones are they?
One subset of this set is the
set itself and the other
subset is the empty set.
So we do have, indeed, 2 subsets
out of that set, which
agrees with the answer
that we found.
Notice that when we count
subsets of a given set, we
count both the set itself, the
whole set, and we also count
the empty set.
All of these are subsets
of our set.
At this point, we can now
pause and you can try to
answer some simple questions of
the same kind as the ones
that we just practiced.